مباشره بعد اعلان توجه البلاد الى جوله
اعاده للانتخابات الرئاسيه كثف الرئيس
التركي والمرشح الرئاسي رجب طيب اردوغان
نشاطاته بدءا بلقاء مع قاده الاحزاب
المكونه لتحالفه الانتخابي لقاءات اردوغان
هذه ترافقت مع تاكيده التزامه بكافه
الوعود التي تعهد بها خلال حملته
الانتخابيه ومن بينها الاهتمام بالمناطق
التي ضربها الزلزال جنوبيه تركيا
ان فوزنا بغالبيه في البرلمان قلب موازين
المعارضه امتنا ترى مهاجمتهم لاهالي
مناطقنا المتضرره بالزلزال بلديات حزب
الشعب المعارض ترتكب فضائح من قطع
المعونات على المتضررين وصولا الى طردهم
من اماكن ايواءهم
في المقابل يواصل تحالف المعارضه دعوته
الناخبين للتصويت لصالح مرشحه كمالكلش
الذي صعد من خطابه تجاه اللاجئين متهما
اردوغان بالتغافل عن دخول عشره ملايين
لاجئ غير شرعي لتركيا طمعا في الحصول على
اصواتهم بحسب وصفه
لن نترك هذا الوطن لطقمه ادخلت عشره
ملايين لاجئ غير شرعي لتركيا طمعا في
اصواتهم لقد عجزوا عن حمايه الحدود امام
التسرب اللاجئين الى اوردتنا ودماءنا كل
يوم تاتي هذه التطورات في وقت انتشرت فيه
صور عبر وسائل التواصل تتحدث عن قيام
بلديه تابعه لحزب الشعب الجمهوري بابلاغ
ناجينا من الزلزال ممن تؤويهم في اماكن
تابعه لها بانتهاء الخدمات التي تقدمها
لهم مطالبه اياهم بالمغادره وصور اخرى
تظهر محاوله اعتداء على احد ركاب القطارات
من قبل اخر يطالبه بمغادره تركيا بسبب زيه
الصنداله
لقد كان ملفاء اللاجئين ومتضررين الزلزال
حاسمين في تحديد توجهات الناخبين في
الجوله الاولى لكنهما في الجوله الثانيه
غير قادرين على احداث تغيير كبير في
قناعات الناخبين
يسعى كل مرشح رئاسي للتركيز على قضايا
يعتبرها مهمه لجلب مزيد من الاصوات ويبدو
ان اختيار اردوغان لمناطق الزلزال
واختيارك للجدار اوغلو لقضيه اللاجئين
يصبان في هذا الاطار المعتز بالله حسن
الجزيره انقره